you know it takes about 20 minutes to
consume two cheeseburgers
medium coke and a medium fries which
basically is over a thousand calories
but it's going to take three hours
of intense exercise to burn off those
thousand calories however if those
thousand calories do not involve
carbohydrates then the rules change
because even if you don't exercise those
calories are not going to be turned into
fat and with being in a low carb diet
your body can actually use those
calories as energy but with a high carb
diet you're not going to be able to use
those fat calories as energy so the
secret of whether you're going to burn
fat or not has to do with how low your
carbs are